[Music]
to give health to cristian cásseres with
his brief news now in
spanish a
nevada highway and highway patrol agent injured
after a long chase
on interstate 15 on tuesday the
patrol that mike loved and was driving died was
crashed  by auto theft suspect
following a chase on the
15 freeway near the
sager avenue exit suspect was shot
and killed officer leaves behind two children
and wife if you would like to
donate visit news now dotcom in
spanish for  more details
on the state's efforts to mitigate
the spread of the virus including the
new delta variant strain everyone
in clark county is now
required to wear a face covering this
started at midnight friday all
stems from various
cdc recommendations and is enforced  to one for those who are
vaccinated
and are already the finalists for the
2021 gold cup edition, which will be
inside the stadium led by  this
sunday the usa and mexico managed to get through to
the final after close matches on
the scoreboard and with endless fouls
while in the other semifinal mexico
managed to go through after a goal scored in
extra time of the game at
minute 99 to be exact putting the
score 2 to 1 and we recommend that you do not
keep the umbrella we will still have
cloudy skies with a chance of
rain for Friday with temperatures
reaching 90 degrees storms are expected
that will last until
Saturday
however heat and sun return
for the week  that comes with
temperatures exceeding 105 degrees
I am Cristian Cásseres consultant and
informative of in you senate in Spanish
good day
[Music]